we have already studied exponents in
school
4 to the power 3 is 4 multiplied by 4
multiplied by 4 which is 64.
similarly the answer to this is 16.
so what will be the answer of any number
raised to 0 let us find out there is an
easy method to do this 2 to the power 4
is 2 multiplied by 2 multiplied by 2
multiplied by 2 similarly 2 to the power
3 is 2 multiplied by 2 multiplied by 2.
what did we do in this step we divided 2
from the above step similarly 2 to the
power 2 is 2 multiplied by 2
we see that we have again divided by 2
if we divide again we obtain the answer
and if we divide this step by 2 again we
will get 1
so 2 divided by 2 is 1
so this is the reason why any non-zero
number when raised to 0 will result in
1. for more such interesting tricks do
subscribe to our channel